the following contains spoilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today in this video I'm bringing
you confirmed reunions for the upcoming
season reunions that are confirmed by
leaked plot and also supported by leaked
photos let's start the Jorah Mormont's
reunion with Daenerys Targaryen Jorah
state was unknown not revealing to the
nearest his greyscale along with the
statement that he doesn't know of a cure
or Shillong disease stakes but that he
will end things before he becomes a
stone man along with confession about
Tyrion Lannister being right about his
love to water on which the nearest
fearfully commanded him to go and find a
cure for his disease so that he could be
by her side when she takes the Seven
Kingdoms back well it seems that Jorah
managed to find a cure since we have a
lot of leaked photos which are
confirming juris signification with the
nearest in Dragonstone in the upcoming
season while the crew was filming is
Maya
durable seen talking to Tyrion is
veneers approached escorted by the
trackers her guard and had a
conversation with Jorah as we can see
from these leaked photos during the
nearest share the talking scene in which
Danny says farewell to her advisor who
in return vows to his Queen as a singles
on the near sense the John Bulger helps
some men to prepare the boat this man as
you can see in the photos our doubts and
injury will also be back in season 7
after long absence that scene doesn't
surprisingly as John Davos ginjury and
Jorah push the boat and went away
together to the north beyond the wall to
try to accomplish John's mission which
have explained you in details in one of
my previous videos now that we know the
jury will be back and they'll be by Dan
East Siders also raising a question the
juror Kirk is greyscale or did he fail
in his mission but returned to Danny
anyway to help her as long as they can
before it spreads that much until it
makes him kill himself well they'll have
to wait a little longer to know the
answer on that question but according to
Luke Blocher will be cured by Samwell
Tarly in old town my guess would be that
he will definitely have his greyscale
cured at the time he reunites with
Daenerys this opinion of mine is
basically constructed by rewashing fifth
episode of the sixth season in majora
revealed his disease of scene in which
we could clearly see Jorah keeping
distance between him and Daenerys in
order to avoid infecting her while he
was keeping up this
in that scene it's not occasionally
photos in which we can see him standing
near Tyrion and Daenerys and later also
sharing a small boat the John Dalton
ginjury all of this proves that durable
at this point already have his disease
cured at least that's how I see it I'm
also wondering how Jura is going to cure
his greyscale there's a possibility that
sambal will learn more about greyscale
while is that said Adel and we'll
discover how to cure it
while more likely possibility would be
the durable fine a mysterious woman
known by the name of Wade who have seen
in the second season and who seems to
have some special capabilities by
special capabilities I mean some sort of
supernatural abilities since she know
about Jura being a spy for King Robert
and also know who stole Daenerys dragons
and we can call it reveal to Jorah that
the resumed Dark Souls and Godfrey were
behind it it's also important to remind
of the scene in which you're visited
Quaid while she was painting a sailor to
protect him while passing across old
Valyria with a statement all who travel
close to the doom must have protection
all of this led me to conclusion that
Cueto might cure Jorah supported by fact
that she knows how to protect people
from greyscale meaning that she might
but only might know how to cure the same
Joris comeback is a confirmed fact while
it's still unknown who Jorah savior will
be but in my opinion there are only two
options each other similarly orc wait
beside this reunion between Jorah and
Danny let's now focus on the reunion
that's been all waiting for a few years
in season 6 vividness the emotional
reunion between John and Sansa and now
that both of them have finally taken
Winterfell in the upcoming season we can
expect full stark reunion net already
mentioned traditional home of House
Stark now that winter is not coming
anymore
now that winter has come beside the joy
that this reunion will bring to us the
north needs ever exist in stark plus
time they've been at Winterfell John and
Sansa had emotional conversation where
pond John has been proclaimed as the
king in the north and the bran will
arrive in the first episodes of season
seven and Arya be later
it won't take soon enough to see all of
them together an interval as John
Vaillant the very first episodes of the
upcoming season receive and accept and
imitate
from Daenerys to come and meet for a
dragon stone as I've already said brand
start to arrive at Winterfell a bit
sooner than Arya so let's see what kind
of proofs are going favored to this
statement
first of all let's highlight the fact
that from only photos there were only
taken a few photos of brand and those
photos weren't even from the shooting
set although brands leaked photos if we
can even call it leaked we're taking my
life cycles preparing for the shooting
in leaked plot there stated at Brandel
past vol until meet with pillar said the
new Lord Commander of the Nights Watch
at Castle black which matches with
reports that Isaac hamsters right an
actor displays brand was filming with an
actor that portrays the Lord said along
with few extras that are portraying
members of the Nights Watch
Brandon demeanor reads arriving at
Castle black is not surprising
additionally something that we've all
seen coming as we've last seen them
being escorted near the wall by Benjamin
while we're all looking forward to see
brands reunion that his siblings at
Winterfell which we are most likely
going to see Brent's presence also means
great threat for everyone else as we've
already seen in season six
after bran was marked by night king the
leader of the undead army now knows
where bran is and will come after him in
addition the mark on bronze can likewise
can neutralize the magic that is curbed
into the wall as a protection from the
White Walkers and their whites just like
the magic words around the cave in which
three-eyed raven along the children of
the forest and Ranbir was neutralized by
brands mark from the night King for all
of you that are wondering if bran is
going to reveal to Jon Snow cook is true
parents are the answer is now he won't
have an opportunity at least not in the
first episode as Jon the live interval
before bran survival still it's going to
be very emotional scene when sense a
finally gets to see her little brother
after a long time
senseless reaction that might have been
leaked by one of HP of teasers this HBO
teaser of the upcoming season is a short
video that has been published a few
months ago and contains four short scene
so which two scenes include Sansa in one
of the scenes we can see sense at the
god suit of Winterfell which is not any
kind of spoiler however she seems a
little bit surprised which led me to
assume that this single represented
force meeting between Brenna
Sansa could represent census first look
at her little brother after all of these
years now let's move on aria after Aria
told to Jack and cigar who she really is
and where she is going a girl is Arya
Stark of Winterfell and I'm going home
it was easy to assume that at some point
of season seven Oroville reunited her
brother and her sister Winterfell and
that we are going to have a full Stark
reunion well re-enter last seen was
expected to be seen at Winterfell as
that is the place where she has been
heading are you managed to surprise a
soul with her last seen me she
satisfyingly and managed her mother and
her brother by slitting all the phrase
throats it's smile in her face after she
already butchered she'd sons and serve
their corpses to him inside the pie
however during the upcoming season
audible finally arrived at her home will
finally arrive at Winterfell but on her
way home she will have to encounter so
which one was confirmed a few weeks ago
or it will finally meet will reunite
with her dire wolf Lemuria that she
forced to leave as she was afraid for
her dire wolf fell being which was the
consequence of nemedia protecting aria
from The Prince Joffrey Baratheon by
fighting Joffrey's arm as this reunion
was confirmed a month ago in this video
I'm going to talk for a few moments
about this reunion as I've already
brought you all details in one of my
previous videos long story short
Maisie Williams was spotted in Calgary
while in the same time there revolves
filming which company by the name of the
instinct animals for film
revealed and at the same time confirmed
with their post on Instagram now of
course that I wouldn't say that this
reunion is confirmed since the same
company doesn't only train animals in
this case wolves for Game of Thrones
series that could have been nothing more
than coincidence but not only that it's
waffles just like older version of
Nirvana Miria older version of the dog
who played Amira in season one but also
the same shooting the white ball by the
name of Quigley was there the same old
that has played Jon's direwolf ghost
which confirms that this shooting was
for Game of Thrones purposes as like
this wasn't enough for us to figure out
that this both will play in Emilia in
the upcoming season on instinct both
both they also have use hashtag winter
is coming which is official family mode
of how stark biome a civilians involved
were filming on the same place in
Calgary their urns
oils of those two shooting together
since actors are not allowed to
interacted wolves and wolves need to be
digitally enlarged now that we know that
I really realized it's a direwolf Miria
by my theory the same devil will reunite
Victoria by saving her life this
prediction that numerous reappearance
will be nothing less but glorious
nemedia will appear in save aria
along with arias second encounter while
heading home you can check out in my
previous videos while they sing a lot
early photos from filming set image most
major characters took their place there
are only few leaked photos so many
civilians if we can even call it leaked
which we're taking out she was preparing
for the shooting well there is no any
leaked photo of aria
there's one short scene from HBO's
official teaser of a new season which
actually gave us something in HBO's
official teaser we can see a few quick
scenes of which one scene includes Arya
Stark as we can see re on horseback very
North clothes in my opinion it's a scene
of arias survival at Winterfell she
finally came back home after all these
years of suffering and that surface
expression with all emotions in it with
emotional scenes between Nuria Ben and
Sansa there will also come to the
prominent difference between two Starks
sisters which will eventually resolve it
bitter Baelish taking the advantage of
and increasing those differences into a
conflict between two sisters Arya always
has had more rigid code while censor has
learned to be more pragmatic or as
skilled killer and once revenge
immediately both Sansa has more subtle
manipulative way of doing things which
you learn from Littlefinger having
developed very different perspectives
are in sense I will clash over the
matter of ruling upon noticing the split
between two sisters Petyr Baelish will
take his chance to take the advantage of
this certain situation by increasing
conflict between Orion Sansa
which won't end as peter baelish wants
according to leaked plot bran stark will
help his sisters to see through little
fingers game which will result its sense
of sentencing Baelish to death and Arya
with carrying this same sentence out if
you are wondering how exactly Peter
Bailey is going to die feel free to
check out the white wedding theory of
mine in which I provided you every
single detail about little fingers
possible death as I've already mentioned
most of those informations I've already
provided in numerous videos so if you
interested about any of those reunions
predictions or theories that I mentioned
in this video feel free to check out my
previous videos for more details I'm
curious which one of these three
reunions is your favorite so make sure
to leave your thoughts in the comment
section down below hope you guys enjoyed
this video if you did please make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and I hope
to see in the next one peace
[Music]